boys Miss welcome to the forge gentlemen
the four of you are here to compete in a
very unique spin in our blade smithing
competition that's going to test every
aspect of your skills when we get done
here the four of you are going to turn
around and head directly back to your
home forges where each pair of Smiths
will be working together at your home
Forge to build an iconic weapon from
history gentlemen we want you to build
this
these Scottish Broad Sword
the Scottish broadsword Rose to
prominence during the late 17th century
this intricate weapon features a Long
double-edged Blade with a dual purpose
basket Hilt designed to protect the hand
and to be used to punch an opponent in
close quarter combat this weapon's
profile and Hilt are similar to the
Scottish back sword featured in season
seven on forged and fire which proved to
be a difficult build and ultimately a
basket Hilt that hurt the user
cost one of the Smiths the competition
gentlemen without further Ado good luck
we will see you in four days
Good Luck Good Luck Good Luck Good Luck
I'm Josh Hardman and I'm 18 years old
from Colorado Springs Colorado I'm Max
harder I'm 18 years old and I'm from
Colorado Springs Colorado
[Music]
our game plan is we're going to split up
the work evenly between us he's going to
work on mostly the blade and I'm going
to work mostly on the hill I'm going to
be doing a multi-bar Twist Damascus with
a solid 1085 wrap on the edge for the
hill I'm going with the mild steel that
way it's easy to move and I don't have
to worry about it splitting or
potentially cracking I've gone through
my normalizing and thermal Cycles so the
next thing to do is quench if this goes
well we'll have a blade that's very
flexible but also have a really strong
Edge
all right one of the really nice things
about working with a partner especially
on a sword is when I pull it out of the
oil I can have Josh set it in the
straightening jig for me and that'll
make it go a lot smoother so now it's on
to hand sanding hand sanding is one of
my least favorite parts of making blades
but this is looking really good so we'll
just move on now it's time to etch
whoa
look at that it's probably one of the
smoothest glue UPS we've ever done
before nice
blade turned out really really good so
now we gotta test it
wow
I'm Dan Lewis my name is Tony Lewis and
we're brothers we are definitely
competitive I mean we're going to take
this challenge we're going to give it
everything we've got and we want to win
we say Lewis has never lose we win or we
learn
we're back in our home Forge and we're
excited to get started the blade has
been out of 5160 spring steel we're not
doing any Damascus in the blade we have
really quenched anything that long
before the blade is just extremely heavy
and there's a lot of potential for it to
end and so we're just constantly
watching to make sure the Blade's
straight
foreign
[Music]
to the basket I've been taking the lead
on that and planting a little bit I
definitely think a little bit bigger is
better in this case we just don't want
anyone to get hurt swinging that sword
or be too tight or uncomfortable for the
judge focus is just getting the final
apple seed Edge to that blade so if it's
sharp but it's also can take a hit so if
it's hit against a shield or something
like that I know that that edge is going
to hold up so I think we got to start to
incorporate some drill holes into the
basket so it's going to take away some
of the weight on the hill
did the final glue up put some final
touches on the blade and we're done
didn't have a moment to sit down and
rest but it feels amazing to be done
with it and we feel like we got a pretty
awesome sword
all right gentlemen this is our Dynamic
strength test the shield chop and foam
tube sliced
all right Max Josh you're up first you
ready for this we're ready okay okay
I'm just super excited I'm really proud
of what we made
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Max Josh first off what I really love is
that pattern on the blade that's that's
just beautiful work that's nicely nicely
done you really didn't lose any Edge I
mean this test wasn't about
what the sword did to the shield but I
certainly wouldn't want to be behind
that thing
your guard I like this is kind of like
that Mary Rose Hilt an early basket Hilt
and I do like this Hilt style because
it's really nice and smooth inside there
and your handle is a good shape it's got
a really nice fluted grip and
controlling this I mean I can cut all
day with this thing so nicely done thank
you
all right Tony Dan you guys ready
I'm ready okay
the home Forge was a lot of hard work
but we feel good about the blade that we
produced
[Music]
foreign
so right off
um scale Wise It's a little on the wide
side you don't quite need that much room
you could have been probably a half inch
tighter on either side and it would have
brought the scale down just a little bit
I like the design you put in there it's
great your Edge right here in The Sweet
Spot
I can literally push my fingertip
against that edge it's just not very
sharp right there
and I don't think it dulled because of
the wooden Shield I don't think it it
took any damage there so I'm just not
sure that that one section was as sharp
as it could have been and I felt it in
the cuts but all in all fine looking
blade it's got a good feel to it so
nicely done thank you
late Smiths welcome to the dynamic
sharpness test
I'm taking your Scottish broadswords
bashing them into this sword then cut
this big carcass
Max Josh you're up first ready ready
all right Josh Max your basket Hilt fits
my hand snugly almost perfectly now your
Edge you got some chips on your blade
here but it didn't affect the cutting
overall the Wheeled ability feels good
and your weapon
it will cut
thanks
Tony Dan your turn you ready you're
ready let's do this
thank you
[Music]
Tony Dan let's talk about your Scottish
broadsword here when I picked it up it's
got a very nice balance to it it's
wieldable it's slightly lighter than the
other blade your handle construction is
comfortable now your Edge you have a
stouter edge here and when I was hitting
on those swords you have one roll on
your blade but your Edge is sharp enough
to cut the pig carcass even on the
stabbing overall your weapon
it'll cut
oh
all right gentlemen all four of you
should be extremely proud of your work
you've brought back two beautiful swords
that did perform well and it made for a
very difficult decision for our judges
but they did make a final decision the
blades missed leaving the forager
Tony and Dan unfortunately your blade
did not make a cut and Dave's going to
tell you why
Tony Dan both blades are fantastic
looking and both blades took some damage
but basically this came down to
Performance and in the end your blade
was just out cut and that's why you're
going home
understand well gentlemen unfortunately
your time in this competition has ended
I'm gonna have to ask you to please step
off the forge floor thank you thank you
good job guys good job guys good job
we're a little disappointed we didn't
make it but we're proud of what we did
this has been an incredible time
absolute blast to be able to do this
together to experience this together as
brothers has been pretty amazing
obviously knowing what we know now we
certainly would have changed that as
geometry a little bit
Max and Josh are excellent bladesmiths I
mean one of them is going to be the
forge and fire champion and we're
excited for him